I am Nick Gillespie with Reason TV and
today we're talking to Rob Campea the
founder and head of Marijuana Policy
Project which is celebrating its 15th
anniversary Rob congratulations on that
what prompted you to start MPP 15 years
ago well 15 years ago there had really
been no one lobbying Congress in almost
two decades on the marijuana issue and
so since I was living in DC at the time
and I saw this gaping need
I started up MPP in January of 95 with
two friends of mine what's the absolute
mission of MPP the mission is to
regulate marijuana like alcohol you
recently in a in or in a recent press
release you talked about kind of 15
great things that happen have happened
in the past 15 years about Marijuana
Policy what's been good about the past
15 years well all the 13 state level
medical marijuana laws have been enacted
in the last 15 years so if you just try
to think back to 15 years ago medical
marijuana being illegal across the
entire country public support for making
marijuana legal for recreational use was
down in the high teens or low 20s so
things have changed not only with regard
to passing these state-level laws we
also passed a marijuana
decriminalization law in Massachusetts
with 65% of the vote and then the Obama
administration has been the the best
presidential administration on the
medical marijuana issue
well now that doesn't necessarily say
very much doesn't say very much now but
I think that was a big victory for our
cause because when you have the you know
US Attorney General saying that the DEA
and then and the Attorney General's
Office is not going to go after Medical
Marijuana providers in the states where
it's legal that then encourages more
activity on the medical marijuana issue
because they don't have that fear of the
federal thugs coming in and kicking in
their doors what what explains the shift
and certainly in medical marijuana I
mean kind of really starts in the in 96
right with California and Arizona
but what what explains the shift towards
a more progressive enlightened attitude
towards medical marijuana well I think
that the the public support for medical
marijuana has been in the high 70s for
many many years so I don't really see a
change in polling on that the reason
that we've had progress in the last 15
years is because we've actually had some
money to spend to take that public
support and to turn it into actual
policy change meaning we have money to
pay for lobbyists in Vermont or Rhode
Island or we have money to do a
signature drive in Montana or Michigan
is really just money that's converting
it into actual policy change what and
now the public opinion as its measured
in polls for legalization of marijuana
is also at an all-time high
what what do you think explains that
because it's not as if this is the late
70s and youth rates are climbing and you
know or where it's very kind of common
out in the public what explains a kind
of enthusiasm for legalizing or at least
decriminalizing marijuana
well the Gallup Organization which is
the only organizations that's done a
consistent Paul since 1969 has found
that making marijuana legal is how they
word it has hit the support level of 44
percent nationwide in 2009 which is a
far higher number than even in the 60s
of the 70s the reason that it's climbing
I think is a couple different things one
is the the proportion of the American
population that's having some personal
experience with marijuana either
personally or they've seen it is at a
higher level than ever before you know
in the 70s and you point out that you
know use was kind of rampant that's true
late 70s teenagers and college students
were smoking openly in public but the
proportion of the entire American
population that used at some point in
the 70s was lower than what we have
today so that demographic change each a
year with the population becoming more
comfortable with it I think translates
into support for making it legal and the
other thing I think that's happened is
that when you have credible institutions
and personalities talking about medical
marijuana and that being in the news a
lot that's changed the image of a
marijuana user from some you know
countercultural
unemployed hippie type
Aereo type to people who are sympathetic
you know grandma who has cancer or the
AIDS patient down the street or Montel
Williams with multiple sclerosis so I
think having a more accurate image of
marijuana users in pop culture is also
then I think turn the heat off a little
bit in terms of people's desire to
incarcerate who were the who are the
responsible drug users or marijuana
users that are not medical marijuana
users in in the public view that you
think help change the image of the pot
user from a kind of unemployed hippie
slacker to people who are you know
smoking pot the way that some people
drink martinis well you know it's it's
tough to really point to a few people I
think it's just the fact that there's so
many hundreds of opinion leaders or
celebrities that have actually come out
you know Carl Sagan was what was one I
think it was very important since he was
a well respected scientist and he was
using for recreational use I don't know
how much play that got I remember it
very clearly cuz I work on the issue but
and then you have high-level politicians
that I think is probably the most
important because it it it makes it
harder for them to be hypocritical at
least so you have Newt Gingrich who is
very open about his past use Clarence
Thomas and then you have the last three
presidents who have used marijuana with
regardless of how honest they want to be
about how they Ward their their answers
and you know and then of course almost
every Democratic presidential candidate
in the last couple of cycles has
admitted to past use so I think when you
have politicians who are the least
likely to admit admitting it makes it
easier for everyone else to admit and
you know what I think when they get
around to admitting future drug use then
it'll totally be time for legalization
Oh be a game-changer what is what is the
what are your hopes for the next 15
years of MPP what are what are the goals
that you want to see achieved well I
just actually finished writing our three
year strategic plan for 2010 to 2012 and
in that plan I sketch out a future where
in four years we could pass legislation
on the federal level that would get the
federal government out of medical
marijuana entirely so basically codify
the Obama administration's informal
policy and then making marijuana
completely legal in at least one state
in the neck
three years meaning California Colorado
or Nevada and that's for recreational or
medical use that's right that would be
complete treating it like alcohol in one
of those states so that's just the next
three years since you asked me about 15
years from now I fully intend on having
marijuana be completely legal in the
entire country 15 years from now what uh
what would be the benefits of legal
marijuana one is that instead of
spending an enormous amount of
government resources going after
marijuana users that it would stead we
would have legitimate businesses making
legitimate money and having employees
would be legal whether it's growing or
selling or packaging or whatever so
that's the money issue secondly with
eight hundred thousand plus marijuana
arrests a year almost all of which are
for simple possession
that's an enormous wear and tear on the
criminal justice system so by making
marijuana legal you're allowing the
police to focus on real crime you're
helping the the workload of the public
defender's courts being clogged judges
time and jail space so there's a the
whole criminal justice system would be
would be helped with it and with
marijuana in Massachusetts when we get
criminalized just for personal
possession we overnight reduce the
arrest rate for all offenses in
Massachusetts by six percent and so six
percent might not sound like a lot but
if you know if you're an overworked
public defender taking six percent of
your of your docket away would be a
really good thing
so there's all kinds of benefits not to
mention of course that if marijuana were
completely legal and regulated like
alcohol than people who need it for
medical purposes would just be able to
go down down to the store and get it
well I want to thank you and
congratulations on the first 15 years I
would hold a blunt up if I had one to
wish you well for the next 15 thank you
very much for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie and I was talking with Rob
Campea a founder of the Marijuana Policy
pro
you